Soon, the government will exert
unprecedented control over
what California doctors can say
to their patients about COVID-19.
We got to stop the disinformation
pipeline.
Essentially, it puts the CDC
in the same room with the
doctor and the patient.
Governor Gavin Newsom signed AB
2098 into law
this September and starting in the
New Year, doctors who disseminate
what the state defines as
misinformation or disinformation
related to the SARS-CoV-2
coronavirus can face
disciplinary action by the
California Medical Board, including
being stripped of their licenses.
These are doctors who are licensed
physicians who carry the same
license as I do, who provide
legitimacy to disinformation.
It is essentially ends
your ability to to
combat bad ideas
put out by public health because
you have this this this looming
power over you
that essentially can end your
career.
Stanford economist and medical
school professor Jay
Bhattacharya was one of several
scientists whose work NIH
director Francis Collins said
needed a quick and devastating
publish takedown.
In an email to Anthony Fauci that
was obtained through a FOIA request,
Bhattacharya was one of the
scientists behind the Great
Barrington Declaration, an
October 2020 open letter calling
for an immediate end to the
lockdowns and use of
an alternative COVID-19 mitigation
strategy called Focus Protection.
Collins called Bhattacharya, who is
a professor of medicine, economics
and health policy at Stanford,
a fringe epidemiologist
along with his cosigners, Harvard's
Martin Kulldorff and Oxford
University's Dr. Sunetra Gupta.
This kind of campaign essentially
put the government in the role of
of suppressing legitimate
public policy debate, public
health debate about what the right
strategy ought to be.
They put their finger on the scale.
The idea was to create this illusion
of consensus around
the lockdowns that didn't actually
exist, which was, I think,
quite dangerous and led to
tremendous bad outcomes for
people all around the world.
I think it's very dangerous
for public health to think that it
has a monopoly on the truth.
Bhattacharya says that same illusion
of consensus is what California
lawmakers are leveraging to
quash dissent among doctors
across the entire state.
The law defines COVID-19
misinformation as medical advice
contradicted by contemporary
scientific consensus,
though, does not specify how to
define such a consensus.
Regardless of your views on the
state of California's coronavirus
response policies or their public
health policies.
I think any person left, right,
liberal, conservative who goes to
their physician and ask them a
question about COVID treatment or
COVID interventions wants
to actually know what their
physician thinks.
They don't, no one wants a doctor
who's just reading from a script
that was written by the California
Department of Public Health.
Aaron Kheriaty is a psychiatrist
and former professor who taught
bioethics at the University of
California Irvine's Medical School.
He was fired after he refused to
comply with the university's
vaccine mandate and published
an essay critical of the policy.
He's also a co-plaintiff in a
lawsuit filed by the new
Civil Liberties Alliance,
a nonprofit law firm that
views the administrative state as
an especially serious threat
to constitutional freedoms.
The suit, which has yet to be heard,
is challenging the California law
on the grounds that it violates
free speech and due process rights.
Science and censorship are,
in fact, incompatible.
The reason is that the
scientific enterprise
precedes and makes progress and
moves forward by conjecture
and refutation.
By generating a hypothesis
and doing a study to potentially
refute the hypothesis,
it has to be an ongoing, open
conversation where debate,
where novel perspectives were
challenges to orthodoxy
or conventional thinking are not
only permitted but welcomed
and then tested against the
empirical evidence.
That's how science proceeds.
So trying to fixate whatever
the current consensus happens to be
and lock it in in law is
something that cannot be challenged
by physicians,
will stifle the progress of
science.
And that's obviously going to be a
bad thing, not just for the practice
of medicine, but for the advance
of medical science and the advance
of treatment recommendations which
need to be revised on an
ongoing basis, especially for a
novel illness like this that we're
still learning so much about.
The bills authors didn't reply to
our interview requests, but
Democratic Assemblyman Evan Low had
this to say upon.
Introducing the bill.
The definition of misinformation is
malicious intent.
It is very specific,
very direct.
And it's important that we help
allow the California Medical Board
to have these definitions in place
to ensure the integrity of
our health care system and provide
an opportunity to save lives.
What would you say is the
proper role of
a medical board?
How does it effectively identify,
you know, cranks or quacks who are
legitimately harming their
patients?
So that's a great question.
It's not an easy question.
Legally, I will I will admit that.
But historically and as medical
boards have functioned really up
until the pandemic,
as far as I have seen,
is that they tend to give physicians
very wide discretionary
latitude to make specific
medical judgments.
The law in California specifies
that the medical board cannot
discipline physicians, for example,
for engaging in complementary or
alternative medical practices
so long as they have some level of
evidence to support
them. So you can do things in
medicine that are outside
of the allopathic mainstream,
and the medical board cannot
discipline you.
And that's good for that's
good for patients who want to seek
out medical providers that are
doing things
that maybe a little bit outside of
the mainstream.
Now, those those doctors
have a duty to give the patient the
information.
This is what we know.
This is what we don't know.
This is the evidence or the lack
of evidence.
If doctors are practicing medicine
that harms patients.
Malpractise laws protect patients
against that.
Those those laws are are
completely legitimate in my eyes.
This law, what it does
is prevents doctors from
dissenting against reigning
ideas in public health, even
when public health is wrong.
Governor Gavin Newsom added a
signing statement that this
bill does not apply to any
speech outside of discussions
related to COVID 19 treatment
within a direct physician patient
relationship.
But Bhattacharya says supporters of
the law hoped to use it to silence
doctors on social media.
The lawsuit alleges that one of
the groups that lobbied for the law,
No License for Disinformation,
whose representatives didn't reply
to our interview request, regularly
threatened him and other dissenting
physicians in the lead up to the
law's passage with a member
of the group tweeting at one
plaintiff.
I look forward to reporting
you to your medical board once
a certain law is passed in
California.
When we reached out, he told us that
I hope the suit gets tossed and
they all deserve to lose their
licenses.
Why did they attack me?
Well, it's not because I'm posing
any risk to patients.
I don't care for patients.
I do research full time.
They attacked me because that the
the idea of the law, the
real purpose of the law is to
limit dissent against
public health generally by
authoritative figures,
especially doctors.
During testimony in favor of the
bill, the founder of No License for
Disinformation pointed to
a physician practicing medicine,
but to a group of doctors who held a
press conference.
A group of physicians calling
themselves America's Frontline
Doctors, led by a licensed
California physician named Simone
Gold,
held a press conference
in what can only be called the most
prolific public showing of
disinformation to date.
If you've gotten the virus, there's
treatment.
That's what we're here to tell you.
Regardless of how one feels about
the message put forth by this
particular group of doctors,
Bhattacharya says that mentioning
them during the debate of the bill
is evidence that the target is
not only physicians in practice,
but any public dissent from doctors.
Although the letter of the law
may say, Just let's limit what
happens in patient rooms, even
that's bad enough, as we've already
discussed.
In fact, the effect of the law
will be to suppress
free discussion by doctors
who are afraid of losing the license
if they disagree with public health
online and elsewhere.
The rationale written into the text
of the law is that COVID-19
has claimed millions of lives
worldwide, including tens of
thousands in California, and
that the safety and efficacy
of COVID-19 vaccines has been
confirmed through evaluation by
the Federal Food and Drug
Administration.
It's plausible to say that it was
true at one time,
but as the virus has evolved
and has as time has gone on
and we have more distance from the
time of vaccination to
the infection, that that claim may
not be as true anymore.
That reasoning also ignores
the fact that a
doctor's recommendation has
to be tailored to the needs of
this specific patient in front
of me. So the.
All or nothing claim that vaccines
are safe and effective
glides over the very
significant, for example,
age stratified differences
in the risks and benefits of
the vaccine glides over
the significant risk and benefit
difference between someone who's
never had COVID and someone who's
already had COVID and has natural
immunity.
So it's not necessarily
the case that
a doctor who's recommending
the vaccine for an 80 year old
with diabetes would also
want to recommend the same vaccine
for a six year old or a 16
year old or even a 26
year old. A law like this doesn't
take account of that aspect
of medical care that needs
to be individualized to the
patient.
Kheriaty says that this law is the
latest example of a trend
towards an increasingly centralized
bureaucratic health system
that prioritizes control
and surveillance over individual
patient needs, a topic he covers
at length in his book, The New
Abnormal.
The subtitle is The Rise of the
Biomedical Security State, which is
kind of the melding of public
health, digital technologies of
surveillance, and police powers of
the state. The laws or the
or the regulations that are
governing the practice of medicine
and governing people's lives at ever
more subtle levels.
Even though a lot of these policies
have been rolled back, I don't think
we've seen the last of of
this kind of movement in this
direction.
And I think a big part of that is
going to be increasingly
sort of squeezing and compromising
physicians, what I call before
physicians, discretionary latitude
there, their ability to make patient
specific judgments, their ability
to to think and to practice
medicine according to their best
judgment, according to their own
interpretation of research
in the medical literature, according
to their own clinical experience.
I worry that doctors are
increasingly going to become
functionaries in a larger
sort of public health apparatus
that doesn't know how to
individualize care to the needs of
specific patients, but takes this
kind of all or nothing approach
to managing a problem like COVID.
What are some of the best ways to
either reverse or
at least halt that to
escape the new abnormal.
We need to end the declared state
of emergency at the federal level
and at the state levels.
So here in California, we're still
operating under a state of
emergency, which gives Governor
Newsom and his appointed
public health officials, unelected
officials, extra constitutional
powers that they wouldn't otherwise
have outside of the emergency.
President Biden announced a month or
so ago on 60 Minutes that the
pandemic was over, which was
true. In fact, it's been over for
quite some time.
But many of his advisers immediately
panicked and said, no, no, no, you
can't say that.
The reason they panicked is
if it's true that
the pandemic is over, then
the state of emergency, the federal
state of emergency, which is renewed
by HHS Secretary
Xavier Becerra with the endorsement
of the president and has been
renewed every three months for the
last three years, almost,
that will have to end.
And when that happens, the
128 additional extra-constitutional
powers that the president gains
during this declared a state of
emergency will have to be
relinquished.
And the powers that HHS
and its its agencies
like the CDC, FDA, NIH
gain will also have
to be relinquished.
The emergency use authorizations
of the vaccines no longer apply
if we're not under a state of
emergency.
The Pfizer and Moderna vaccines
are fully FDA approved for
adult use, but an emergency
use authorization still covers
use among minors.
Kheriaty also favors decentralizing
research funding so that less
of it is directed by federal
officials like Anthony Fauci
and Francis Collins at the National
Institutes of Health, who can make
or break the career of a scientist
by funding or denying them grant
money. The lawsuit against
California was filed in November
and has yet to be heard by a judge.
If no ruling is issued in the coming
weeks, AB 2098
will become California law
starting January 1st.
The fundamental problem is the loss
of authority in public health
because they have squandered their
authority to correct the record
rather than being honest
about what was known and not known.
Calling for more studies when
they're needed to resolve these
uncertainties.
Public health should not rule over
the public. Public health should be
partners with the public in
promoting health.
I think humility would be the
watchword in my reformed public
health.